moving on to page
118 and 119.
turning icchio into nicky
on the omote
you do exactly the same thing so think
of it as
taking down into the echo position
you can try
the
the gripping of the wrist and the elbow
you can try this and then when it's down
near your knee
keep your
front foot
whatever is forward let's say you know
you're going to take with your right
hand the rest your left hand the
elbow you take it down now your left leg
needs to be deep enough
on the entry
once you've about to take them down
place your knee first instead of hitting
the side of their body
place your
your
your groin area but with your left knee
forward so your left you know you you've
come down
it's on your
um
right leg at the moment there the wrist
with your right hand
with your left hand
you lock their elbow joint
so the pressure
is against the
right leg
but the wrist is pinned there there
their wrist is pinned with your right
hand
so you can then remove your right hand
slide it along
you slide it along
the back of the hand
you use your thumb
to turn it so they can grip their hands
so their hands will be
like a kind of guy shall be
this this way
you'll be holding
you'll be holding just like a coat of
ice but you'll be holding their hand
and thumb
like this
and like the book says if you want to
carry on ikea
you
keep the hand in twisting in the in a
clockwise motion
clockwise only motion
then with the left leg you step in
hitting them in the side the ribs taking
them down into the icc
the right hand's going to keep winding
it downwards
what happens is that we're not aware of
our emotions
and this hand instead of going around in
a circle
as we go down
and the body is even that's going in
like this because you've hit them with
your
left
knee and the ribs even though they're
going down what happens is we start to
press
like this
on the hand
in the icc position so the thumbs on the
top you're rotating around
but it should be
like a a stabbing like a stabbing one of
the kimi joes i think it's the third
kimi jo
where you you drive it's like driving a
dagger into the side of their body
it's this feeling
you've got their arm you've got their
wrist
you hit them in the ribs and you drive
it this way but don't add
to this
this motion so
the power is really in hitting them in
the ribs
with the knee
controlling of the elbow and then you
press it down as a whole thing
and you place the arm down flat in front
of you a t-angle as the pictures show
you it
now
to do
to move on to nick here the only
difference is all of this is the same
but nicki oh now you apply this inwardly
and instead of
at this end this angle
this angle with their body and their arm
you bring it up and you apply it so it
becomes more downwards
and your aim is
in both of them to pin their shoulder
the shoulder you're trying to pin their
shoulders down on the ground to end it
quickly rather than go for like a long
walk
but the nikki oh you adjust this just a
little more
by this pressure
the pain will stop them
walking
and it will drive it more
so okay so body science
ikea
nicu then you go down on your knees or
standing and you can do the pin
okay so it's a very subtle difference
and you need to understand the
sensitivity as well as the direction
and understanding this what would give
you a professionalism and much more
control of your partner
i hope you test it out and each film
that is given to you
hasn't just been plucked out of the air
it's taken me many years of study to get
to this stage
so please don't just think oh when's the
next film coming when's the next film
coming
you need to study and study and the
films that are already on the system
may take your lifetime to understand
so even if you don't understand them now
watch them
over and over
it's not worth my advice it's your
choice
try to understand what's going on in my
head and see if you can capture that
so it's not just about angles
it's about
sensitivity like i said the whole
style like you know has a lot of
sensitivity in it
they're feeling they're searching
we do search and feel but not in the
same way it can look much more
like control
perhaps we want to become more precise
in our work you know
but it's up to you
okay it's very difficult and you'll need
to see the films with the book
to understand the fullness of the
technique
good luck and
we'll talk again soon